me too movement is not only bringing the
issue of sexual harassment to light but
also highlighting what role men have in
the discussion our Alex Wagner recently
spoke with a group of five accomplished
men about the responsibilities they feel
to address sexual harassment and gender
equality one of them was producer Judd
Apatow is it awkward when you confront
another man about sexual harassment Judd
I don't think so I mean when you run a
television set you have a lot of
employees and you're really trying to
create an environment where everybody
there feels comfortable that if they
have an issue they could go to the
people who run the set and it will be
taken care of it really is one of the
situations where I think the head people
set a tone for decades author and
educator Jackson Katz has called on the
men to set the tone and speak out he
delivered this message in a popular TED
talk called violence against women it's
a men's issue that talk has received
more than three and a half million views
there's so many men who care deeply
about these issues but caring deeply is
not enough we need more we need more men
with the guts with the courage with the
strength with the moral integrity to
break our complicit silence and
challenge each other and stand with
women not against them Jackson Katz is
the founder and president of MVP
strategies he's provided sexual
harassment and violence training for
several sports teams and the military
good morning good morning it's a men's
issue what does that mean it means that
historically people have seen issues
like sexual harassment and domestic
violence and sexual assault as women's
issues that some good men help out with
but a big part of my work is helping
people to think differently about this
subject and I would say that these
aren't women's issues that good men help
out what they're actually men's issues
men have an incredibly important role to
play men are committing the vast
majority of the abuse the harassment of
the violence and until men stand with
women as are as their partners and
allies in this work we're only gonna be
cleaning up after the fact we need to do
a whole lot more and so if I'm a man
which turns out I am and I am not be and
I'm not doing anything and I might think
well what's my role so what am i how am
I supposed to think differently all men
I think at all levels of theirs at all
levels of society and whatever their
sphere of influence have to make it
clear to the people around them that
abusing women in any way verbally
emotionally physically sexually is
unacceptable not just because it's
illegal and they're gonna get in trouble
but because the peer culture doesn't
accept that other men as well as women
don't accept it this is a message that
adult men need to be sending not just to
each other although that's true but to
young men and boys who have to hear it
from men as well as women that the way
to treat what you know treating women's
respect is not an option it is is
mandatory it's just how you treat people
with respect and dignity and if you
don't do it you're gonna be in trouble
not just again with the authorities but
with your friends with your peers with
your teammates with your classmates with
your colleagues if we can change the
social norms in male culture that allow
this behavior to go on you're gonna see
a significant diminution because it's
not about individual sick men who are
doing this a lot of men who are
committing these acts of abuse and
harassment are otherwise normal men
they're mostly normal men that's right
perpetrators outside of this or normal
men in all situations that's what I mean
by that because what is our perception
what do you mean the perception I think
is that some you know Freddy Krueger
like twisted character is committing
these acts of aggression or abuse like
on college campuses rapists are some
some monstrous individuals they're
normal guys most guys who commit rape on
college campuses are otherwise normal
guys they go to class or they don't go
to class they're in fraternities or
they're not theirs they're athletes or
they're not they're just normal guys but
the question that that begs is why are
not otherwise normal guys doing this and
what does it mean to be normal in this
society in other words if it's not just
crazy individuals but actually much
broader than that then it implicates the
various institutions of the society that
shape what we expect from men and boys
I'm really curious cuz you pioneered
this bystander training what does that
mean how do you do it
well the bystander approach is a way to
move beyond the perpetrator victim
binary in other words instead of
focusing on Menace perps and women as
victims or women as perpetrators and men
as victims or any combination it focuses
on everybody in a given period I stand
er which is a friend a teammate a
classmate a colleague a co-worker right
second honor code yeah code sure but but
it's it's giving people tools to
challenge and interrupt abusive behavior
when they see it and not just at the
point of attack give us an example give
us an example you're a guy and you're
hanging out with
guys and there are no women in the room
and one or two of the guys start making
sexist and degrading comments about
girls or women instead of laughing along
or being silent in the face of that it's
interrupting that by saying hey that's
not funny man you can't talk about like
that it's just like with racism if
you're a white person and you're hanging
out with a group of white people and one
or two of those white people start
making racist comments if you don't
challenge them on that in a sense your
silence is a form of consent and
complicity when their racism what the
president called locker room talk yeah
you made an interesting observation
about the Golden Globes the other night
that I hadn't thought of until you until
you pointed it out
yeah the Golden Globes was an incredible
moment it wasn't just because of the
awards for the people who did great work
it was an incredible historical and
cultural moment where so many women were
coming forward and talking publicly in a
very you know with a bright spotlight
about not only experiences that they had
had but highlighting the experiences
women all over the world and it's a
great historical moment but yet all the
men who came up to get awards and
present didn't say anything they didn't
say anything and on the red carpet yes
some of them said you know we support
women I'm very proud of her what we
didn't hear from men either on the
arrival or from the stage at all was men
saying as a man I'm in a position here
because of because of the bright
spotlight to say as a man I support
women and I'm gonna do whatever I can to
challenge other men to stand up and
speak up and support women and make this
a movement that is transparent you think
they didn't say anything I think a lot
of men don't know what to say I think a
lot of men don't haven't ever heard
other men say this so they haven't seen
it modelled I think a lot of men are
afraid of stepping in it in other words
they don't know what to say and
therefore they worry that they're gonna
say the wrong thing and they get pushed
back so I mean I think that there's a
generous way of thinking about why men
didn't say anything not that they're
perpetrators but but they just don't
know what to say and I think part of
what we're doing here is just showing
men you can talk about this and please
talk about it yes please talk about it
Jessica have you here thank you thank
you thank you so much